the teaser trailer for Mary Poppins
returns just dropped with the sugary
dose of nostalgia and a first look at
the magical nanny played by Emily Blunt
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and this is my teaser trailer breakdown
from the Mary Poppins sequel where I'll
be explaining some cool Easter eggs and
other details you might have missed and
be sure to let me know in the comments
about anything you spotted - it looks
like oscar-winning costume designer
Sandy Powell has done a wonderful job
with the characters costumes in fact the
new film includes an easter egg - the
original movie in the form of the Robin
on Mary Poppins has that little
decorative bird is a callback to the
Robin which featured in the song a
spoonful of sugar and which accompanied
Mary as she sang to the bank's children
about how to tidy up their room and the
new teaser trailer also includes another
tribute to that famous song in the scene
where emily Blunt's mary admires her
reflection in the mirror before walking
away only for her reflection to stay
behind watching and raising an eyebrow
as Mary leaves that's a throwback to the
mirror which Julie Andrews Mary took out
of her carpet bag and put on the wall in
the banks family home and when she was
readying to leave the house putting on
her hat and coat in front of that mirror
her reflection took on a life of its own
and joined her and singing a spoonful of
sugar before watching Mary leave and
then winking and if you look carefully
you can also see this movie's version of
Mary's Parrothead umbrella which
apparently is going to be able to talk
just like it did in the first film and
if you think I'm gonna keep my mouth
shut any longer that will be quite
enough of that thank you
of course the sequel is returning to
Cherry Tree Lane and once again we'll be
meeting the bankses neighbor Admiral
boom whose ship inspired home has been
updated for the new movie the filmmakers
have explained that although the sequel
is not going to be an exact reproduction
it will have familiar elements from the
first film in fact according to the
movies production designer they want us
to feel like we're seeing something
we've seen before but were really seeing
it for the first time as well as Admiral
boom mr. binnacle is also returning for
the sequel though they'll both be played
by new actors and I wonder if their
habit of firing a ship's cannon twice
daily will
also be making a comeback also here in
the shot of Cherry Tree Lane is what
looks like a milkman pushing a crate of
milk bottles the milkman is a new
character for the sequel and appeared in
orthopedist book Mary Poppins opens the
door and just as Admiral booms house in
Cherry Tree Lane draws on the one in the
1964 classic without being exactly the
same so to the kite we see in the
trailer is clearly inspired by the green
kite with the yellow trim which belonged
to the bank's children in the original
film and like that original kite the one
in the new film has clippings from The
Times newspaper on it and its tail is
also made from one of the votes for
women's sashes worn by mrs. banks this
shot here also looks like a literal hat
tip to the original mr. banks as he has
a similar look and if you remember in
the classic film mr. banks had his
bowler hat punched through when he was
sacked from the bank just before he
returned home for the let's go fly a
kite song with his children now if
you're a little unclear on the movies
timeline the sequel takes place twenty
or so years after the original which was
set in 1910 that means Mary Poppins
returns will take place in 1930s
Depression era London Michael and Jana
now grown-up and Michael has three
children Georgiana Belle and John who
are the three new children we see in the
trailer Michael and Jane are obviously
delighted to see Mary Poppins again and
according to the movie's synopsis the
magical nanny returns to the banks
family after Michael suffers a personal
loss together with the streetlamp Leiter
Jack who's played by lin-manuel Miranda
of Hamilton and Marana Fame Mary Poppins
will use her unique magical skills to
help the family rediscover the joy and
Wonder missing in their lives on the
subject of fern if you were concerned
about the rather dark color palette in
the trailer then I think this might just
be how the movie sets up the story first
of all it's set during the Great
Depression Michael's lost his wife and
the weather is literally dark and stormy
but as we saw in the first film changes
in the wind signal Mary Poppins coming
and going and the moment she appears in
the teaser the sky starts to brighten
and we get stronger colors Disney has
also released some promo photos from
other scenes that aren't in the trailer
and they give us a good hint of some of
the fun colorful
we can look forward to in the final film
so what did you think of the teaser
trailer for Mary Poppins returns and
were there any other cool details you
spotted let me know what you thought in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
don't forget to like share and subscribe
to get all my new videos plus while
you're here check out more of my Disney
and trailer breakdown videos by tapping
the screen now thanks for watching and
see you next time you became movie
lovers